whatsapp belli miei carissimi oggi siamo
tornati su minecraft è la cosa che mi
piace dire è che sono con pietro ciao
ciao
bene allora rimasti su mai caparco alla
6 premi shift nota ieri sul blocco non
cade giù ok ok moda ma mangiano una
mamma che lavora già fatta in agenzia
con tra l'altro bravo e che siamo stati
bravi quale amico e chiuse chiuso e
questo 4 chiuso all aspetto cede andata
e venite qua sembrava dovesse entrare
vieni vieni bravo e qualche sono rifare
scusa ok
mamma mia mamma mia ragan amber one qua
l'hai fatto ce l'ho fatta ho finito non
ci credo
cioè non c'è ancora cento quindi presumo
sia la seconda parte questa è come lo
hai visto tu in tre parti non si è
rivelato lo giuro qual era più gli si
aspetta che mi fa la cosa più bella
della vita giusy schiantato con una
facciata fortissimo si è sentito uno
splatter che proveniva dall anima
gromyko è stato bellissimo
vabbè c'è una tasca la sesta roba o mio
dio
ma che sa dove andare di qua perfetta e
qui faccio se della grappa ma sede scena
come mai nel mondo come poi di fare ma
no ma è fattibile nella vita del vieni
qua e la roba inguardabile rai non è già
facendo due perfetto bravo a precedere
cosa c'è questa roba è una roba
inguardabile vai avanti ovvero qui entra
un deficiente reca un deficiente valore
c'è un problema di valore no no no no no
a sei caduto dall'altra parte continui
fare all'inverno bravo c'è casino recano
vasta parte giuro ma sono idiota niente
scherzavo siamo fatta cioè fatto
scherzavo sono io scemo non avevo visto
un altro pezzo è bello c'è un letto
sfatto stesso cercando amico mi vedo a
hua guarda io ci credo non ci credo
ti ho fatto ma cosa ho fatto
mamma mia cosa ho fatto cioè tra costati
ho risparmiato tra l'altro che una idea
sinistra sinistra già fatto mamma ti
voglio bene grande quanto una casa in
questo momento è niente abbiamo perso
dovevamo andare sulla beta trovai
sbloccato il punto
ok già fatta ce l'ho fatta bastava a
spostarsi il laterale però spostarti
laterale di eni cadrà anche senso è
premi il tasto di mentre guardi la scala
poi ovviamente dobbiamo riguardare la
scala di rivolto
bravi grazie rivolto con la faccia verso
la scala così mentre scendi guardando la
scala ora questo è decisamente difficile
a guardarsi il fatto è che vieni
annientate che davis altre non lo sono
anche questo devi fare con il problema
per farvi vedere faccio prima io
questo è sicuro da qua non ho capito che
i periodi ti guardo da quattro to fail
io faccio ci provo
ave maria piena di grazia signore con
pietro muori pietro pietro morto ci ho
fatto sport è così maledizione bravo
grazie prego se stato un ora e mezzo
aliese caduto subito vedove gli ascap
andare avanti e perfetto aspetta aspetta
76 aspetta
ok ti sono vale quella fine no manca
ancora un pezzo e non ho idea di come
farlo quando andate un attimo ciò che è
bene non ho idea di come fare questa
cosa è un albero 2 comme faje se idiota
no no no pietro no perché spiegami
perchè perchè qualche porca vacca perché
dai di provare a fare a ok anno è più
easy di punta 6 aprile
no facile no fatica dry prove che play
di let's go bere rai linde pozzo vieni
pietro allo sprint dai principi in ci
sarà un checkpoint
non c'è c'è non ci sono più i check
point se muori riparti da capo in questo
gioco va bene è arrivato vabbè allora
pronti a fare arrivato aspetta guarda
che c'è accessi slot non ce n'è poi ho
capito se con secondo forse sì ho capito
ma noi non possiamo iniziare a zero se
cadiamo luce della roba sulle cose
tranne come fai a ciel ed era aspetta
dove sono io in questo momento sono
aggrappato al ed era come posso andare
sulla quale si no
ma venne ma lo sapevi tu questo non lo
sapevo proprio mai nella vita come fatto
salire lo so botta di fortuna sono
uscito sono caduto come un cretino
ok da un cretino che ce l'ho fatta non
sapevo neanche questa cosa ok
let's go obici let's go home again bates
c'è poi è veramente tipo cessata in
questa parte vieni via vieni poche
prefetto che poteva anche se ci date ho
preso il medico troppo tranquillo è vero
ha dimenticato gli anni avanti fin qua è
ok poi non non è ok sulle staccionate no
formazioni stagionate forse qua e di
quell'altro fi quelli fai con la mano a
ok ok ok non l'avevo visto scusa paese
forte grazie a ok direttamente nell'anno
stata sta cosa non si è caduto ok bene è
una volta qua arrivo alla fine siccome
non ci arrivo alla fine
aiutami pietro e prendo c'è il
professore poi di trasporti va bene e
poi muoio muoio così arrivino è come
faccio scusa lo saltare ma non ci arriva
ma non ci arriva
aiutami pietro guarda quanti block
indietro sono caduto rispetto ad allora
cadere come si fa a fast era sì ci sono
forte
solo fortissima una persona brava grazie
sono e non celarsi presso il play tali
aspettare un attimo che vi aspetta un
attimo
ok l'offeso vieni il porca vacca quanto
stamina alto rispetto a prima semina
quando l'ho chiamato ditte tantissimo se
guardi c'è veramente tanto rispetto
all'inizio sentivo di fare una roba non
secondo di pausa dai perché se ho
sentito che che ti stai distruggendo il
cervello perché lo voglio farlo
new york basket più che altro non
commetto più in questo momento aveva
falla la pausa mi sorprendo bene queste
cose da mina e portiamo una pausa dai 5
minuti ce l'hai fatta
non la facciamo la pausa la e ciò che
gioca a fare a pausa di cinque minuti no
bravissimo così facciamo la pace si
continua a dire questa frase di
scommettere ariano fino alla fine hai
fatto scusa come ha fatto così e quindi
saltato da all'albero non acqua dritto
devi saltare però aspettare
effettivamente hai ragione anche tu come
il che non mi chiama rifatto scusa
ecco che bello questo qua pausa si pausa
pausa
no perché vanno avanti finiamo tutti ma
il numero die che finiamo tutto avrà in
pausa in pausa pietro siamo in pausa è
questo quello che facciamo non è serio
park al accaparrava aveva rapito in
pausa con the forte è perfetto arriva da
prendere un attimo un po d'acqua il
centro progetto on the 196 già sopra due
già fatto le cose abbiamo fatto la pausa
nel caso lo fosse chiesta tra un taglio
e l'altro anche se non si vede io sono
andato accesso pagato
ho saltato guardali guardali guarda
guarda li guardo livore guardali guarda
l'isola dalla fine consente aver così
arrivato alla fine ragazzo è un bel
check point cioè sono cioè il point di
ieri grazie prego non è che doveva qua
cosa vedo
tra l'altro qua se cadi muori a temi
come patito e va bene ma siamo due
caschi mori allora se tu sei una persona
stupida nell'anima magagna david onde
nido di sfogarti contro gli altri di
farlo ucciditi voglio pure 9 bene può
torna da portate una di quelle testate
fra il contorno anche alla fine più che
altro bravo questa e la gioia per gli
occhi te lo dico guarda che manca poco
alla fine manca poco
te lo giuro cioè non troppo guarda gli
alberi dove stanno come fai a flor e di
milano sono fatto niente più spinto
forse aia che vale due volte come tratto
se finisce nell'acqua come ho fatto
spetta secondo bastava non correre
è da qui che mori ciao amico dai che due
toccamenti come fatto girare scusata ok
hai fatto
no no no no giobatta mai fatto esaltare
amico
allora ti si è cagato addosso che potevo
buttarti giù che hai fatto finta di
niente
vieni vieni vieni vieni vieni che manca
poco alla fine vieni vieni che sono
carico vieni qua basta salire con la
cascata volendo
ci sono dei problemi non capisco e per
confonderci per confonderci di venire
qua guardami
ah ok ho chiesto il suo fatto
proteggevano era difficile da fare
questa parte ma pur con quale lascia
stia sfide e poi sono caduto non
difficile proprio un deficiente non è
che scalzato o no no dai
no no no no dai no no no dai dai dai
fatti la vita bellissima volta perché
non sa parte anche è però da qua ha da
poco dall'altra credo che bravo è un
fenomeno
attenzione non so se devo arrivare
all'ultima forse si no non ero arrivato
alla fine mancava l'ultimo salto porca
eva ok spiega ci riprova aspetta mamma
mia mamma mia uccidi quindi ragazzi
concludiamo quell'episodio siamo
praticamente quasi alla fine il prossimo
credo sarà l'ultimo a meno che non siano
troppo difficili
l'ho detto è 300 ragazzi consenso che il
momento mi piace a chiavari sono come
detto descrizione che altrove si chiede
non ci vediamo
[Musica]